[Musik]
nelson und sebastian decken die geheime
zutat in fertig mariniertem grillfleisch
auf einen natürlich ihr erfahrt was
wirklich drin steckt wenn die industrie
mit fantasievollen zutaten die limette
chili oder kräuter paprika mariniert zur
unterstützung hat nelson müller wieder
gäste eingeladen
[Musik]
heute für eine ganz besondere und
aufschlussreiche grillparty
nächstens gäste haben grillfleisch
eingekauft und vieles davon ist
praktischerweise schon vor mariniert was
sagt überhaupt zu diesen marinierten was
wie steht ihr denn dazu ja jetzt schnell
grillen möchte sagt mit kollegen und
sagt wir wollen wir in europa etwas vor
mariniertes weil man lecker essen möchte
sollte schon früh stück fleisch ein
für mich ist das so da kann man
überhaupt nicht die qualität des
gleichen teilen weil es halt voll
mariniert ist und im endeffekt sieht man
ja gar nichts außer die marinade was ist
denn da drüben gewürzte speisen salz
reis chris zucker würzen granulat die
grundsubstanz da gibt es ja die
deutschen geschichte mit diesen
mariniertem fleisch das man eben doch
natürlich auch einiges verdecken kann wo
es vom geruch gar nicht so schlecht ist
davon vom geruch aber es trifft
natürlich extrem nach der marinade klar
was hersteller mit marinade so alles
anstellen können zeigt uns sebastian
läge der 34-jährige ist
produktentwickler und arbeitet für die
lebensmittelindustrie
[Musik]
dass ein papa enzyme also papa ihn ein
enzym was auf papier gewonnen wird
jetzt sind sie da
[Musik]
bei marinade grillfleisch und solche
sachen kann man das einsetzen um fleisch
wirklich zeit zu machen ja ein
natürlicher fleisch zwar ein enzym ideal
zur verbrauchertäuschung cs fleisch wird
wieder weich
völlig geschmacksneutral ähnliche
eigenschaften ist zum beispiel auch
milchsäure also milchsäurebakterien
haben auch eine sehr also eine
eigenschaft und fleisch zu machen
der sogenannte zart macher muss auf der
zutatenliste in der regel nicht
deklariert werden um zu zeigen wie er
wirkt schiebt sebastian lege unsere
behandelten fleischproben kurz in den
ofen
[Musik]
es ist soweit gewirkt dass man komplett
die schichten davon unterstreichen kann
was normal bei normal gegangen
vielleicht nie möglich wäre dass somit
messer ab zu streichen man sieht auch
richtig ist klebt ja und wenn man sieht
wenn man nur leicht über streicht hat
man dieses fleisch wie passte was man
die leber aufs brot streichen könnte
für die fleischindustrie ein günstiger
trick um billigware an die käufer zu
bringen
für den ehrlichen koch nur im notfall
erlaubt für den hausgebrauch natürlich
auch interessant wenn da einer sagt
mensch das fleisch möchte ich gerne
butterweich haben die schwiegermutter
kommen kann nicht mehr so gut kauen kann
man natürlich auch papa pürieren in eine
schöne marinade geben dass er mit dem
fleisch übergießen über nacht ziehen
lassen hat man ähnliche effekte der
trick mit den pfad machern ist nicht
gesundheitsschädlich aber oft ein weg um
schlechte qualität zu verstecken
für nelson müller kommt das nicht in
frage sein tipp selber marinieren oder
noch besser das fleisch erst dann
bestreichen wenn es fast schon fertig
ist lackieren
so heißt es bei den profis sojasauce ist
in tandoori ein bisschen honig aufkochen
lassen zusammen damit stärker abgebunden
bis es eben diese sirup artige
konsistenz bekommt und die streiche
jetzt auch und dann wird es eben ganz
kurz bevor vor dem servieren noch mal
schön heiß gekocht dass man eben so eine
art lackierung hat und dass so ein
bisschen ähnlich wie spareribs an der
geschmack
[Musik]
ich geb dir nicht bei vor mariniertem
grillfleisch das bietet für mich einen
hohen unsicherheitsfaktor
ich weiß nämlich dass in diesem
marinaden alles mögliche hinein gegeben
wird und das ist dann für mich einfach
schwierig zu erkennen wie gut die
qualität ist da stellt sich dann doch
ihr natürliches stück fleisch gebraten
oder gegrillt einfach veredelt mit salz
und pfeffer fertig oder eben marinade
selber machen
aber wie steht es mit der verpackung
auch hier sind nelson gäste eher
misstrauisch minuten stücks ist ja
eigentlich so lang ist so wenn das
fleisch schön rot das dann hat das schon
lange so man denkt an eine qualität oder
ein geschmack und eigentlich hat es
jetzt eine ähnliche farbe angenommen
sie ist wahrscheinlich an der verpackung
dass sie sehr künstlich aus also das ist
total künstlich abgepacktes
frischfleisch eigentlich ein widerspruch
in sich oder nicht knapp zwei drittel
des in deutschland verkauften
frischfleisch kommen nicht mehr vom
metzger um die ecke sondern aus der
plastik packung die hersteller
versprechen bei fleisch aus der
luftdichten plastikschale einen großen
vorteil nach dem einkauf soll es im
kühlschrank tage lang lagern können
aber wie kann das funktionieren und ist
das für die gesundheit tatsächlich
unbedenklich
[Musik]
im labor lassen wir hackfleisch proben
untersuchen abgepacktes schon vier tage
alt und frisches vom metzger das
ergebnis in der vermeintlich frischen
probe finden wir 50 mal mehr keime als
in der abgepackten euro sollte man
dieses gehackte von metzger besser nicht
mehr essen dann natürlich auch diese
produkte gut durch erhitzen den wänden
keime vorhanden sind dann können die
abgetötet werden im kern eine temperatur
von 70 grad über mehrere minuten
erreicht wird dann ist man auf der
sicheren seite
aber warum bleibt abgepacktes fleisch
länger frisch die antwort ist simpel
chemie in der luftdichten verpackung
befindet sich ein spezielles gasgemisch
in unserem fall besteht es zu 74 prozent
aus sauerstoff und zu 18 prozent aus
kohlendioxid in dieser sogenannten
schutzatmosphäre wird der
alterungsprozess des fleisches
verlangsamt allerdings gibt es neben der
haltbarkeit einen weiteren für die
industrie noch wichtigeren effekt
welchen das sieht man beim vergleich
schon auf den ersten blick das fleisch
aus der schutzatmosphäre ist auffallend
rot
einen tag altes frisch leicht dagegen
hat schon hellbraune stellen
das sieht nicht ganz so appetitlich aus
spielt aber für den geschmack noch keine
rolle
die schutzatmosphäre sorgt also dafür
dass das fleisch schöner aussieht als es
eigentlich ist das muss man sich
vorstellen wie bei meissen mendes rostet
es kommt zu einer farbänderung durch
diese hohen sauerstoffgehalt der sich
dann einen blutfarbstoff anlagert bleibt
es schön rot es sieht sehr sehr frisch
aus und das ist natürlich der vorteil
für die industrie und für den handeln
weil natürlich fleisch über längere zeit
schön rot rosig aussehen kann
die schutzatmosphäre dient also auch der
optik die uns beim einkauf anlocken soll
und die qualität um die zu prüfen darin
wir frisches und abgepacktes fleisch und
unterziehen es einem drop test wie viel
kraft muss das messinstrument im labor
aufwenden um das fleisch zu teilen
ergebnis bei abgepacktem fleisch wird
mehr kraft benötigt als bei frischem das
bedeutet abgepacktes wird schneller c je
länger in der packung umso mehr
[Musik]
abgepacktes ist also täuschend rot und
oft sehr aber schmeckt es denn
wenigstens genauso gut wie frisches wir
testen hackfleisch einmal frisch einmal
aus der packung im grill werden beide
proben auf die gleiche temperatur
erhitzt dann folgt eine blindverkostung
unter wissenschaftlichen bedingungen
sechs lebensmittel chemikerinnen testen
die geschmacks eigenschaften von
abgepacktem und frischemarkt fleisch sie
sitzen in getrennten kabinen und dürfen
nicht miteinander sprechen drei
testkriterien werden abgefragt fahrt
haid saftigkeit und aroma auf einer
skala von eins bis sechs werden die
blindproben bewertet je höher die
wertung umso besser der geschmack
das resultat ist eindeutig das
abgepackte fleisch erreicht einen
durchschnittswert von nur 3,5 das
frische bringt es auf 45
warum ist das so wieder lassen wie
hackfleisch proben analysieren wieder
abgepacktes nach vier tagen in der
schutzatmosphäre und zum vergleich
frisches die wissenschaftler vermuten
dass der sauerstoff der schutzatmosphäre
mit dem fett im fleisch reagiert haben
könnte
und tatsächlich die färbung der beiden
proben zeigt an dass fleisch aus der
verpackung ist mit dem sauerstoff
oxidiert das sorgt für einen leicht
ranzigen geschmack ein hoher
sauerstoffgehalt kann dazu führen dass
fleisch schneller ranzig wird das ist
schneller c wird weil natürlich der
sauerstoff mit den inhaltsstoffen im
fleisch zum beispiel mit dem fett oder
auch mit den proteinen mit den eiweißen
reagieren können aber auch gefährliche
stoffe wie das cholesterol oxid kann
können durchaus entstehen wenn längere
zeit der hohe sauerstoff mengen im
fleisch franken zu
immerhin eine aktuelle studie des
bundesinstituts für risikobewertung
kommt zu dem ergebnis dass vom schönen
roten abgepackten fleisch keine
gesundheitsgefahr ausgeht
aber qualität und geschmack können
leiden
unser fazit deshalb besser anstehen und
fleisch ganz frisch an der theke kaufen
und dann nach dem einkauf möglichst bald
zu bereiten
[Musik]
marien ihr tier beim grillen lieber
selbst sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch essen wissen wollt
dann abonnier die zdf besser esser und
schaut in die nächsten zwei clips